知識はあればあるほど良いものではありません
頭では知識の世界なんですよ
それもあればあるほどいいというものじゃないんです
まず 前と同じく 何のために知識ということを勉強しなきゃいけない
承知がない人間は肉体の維持管理のために知識を得るんです
人間というのは ただ肉体の維持管理のために知識を得ているんですよ
また 知識が増えることは刺激になるので
経済的な結果がなくても知識を得ようとするんです
それで人類の知識はすべてその 2つで割るんです
経済学もすべての学問は
数学も何でもかんでも
ただ肉体のために 肉体を維持管理するために得る知識ですよ
いろいろ新しいものを勉強したら
それでもう金儲かりますからね
金儲かるということは肉体を維持することでしょうに
もう一つ知識があるんですよ
金にはなりませんだけど
刺激にはなる 考古学とか
3000年前のなんか食器の破片見つけたとかね
で なんかあの人類の初めてのラーメンかな
もう何かもうもう化石になって見つけたとかもニュースもありましたけどね
どこかで中国で それまた 3000年前のもので
その土地古から人間はラーメンを食べていたとか
だから それであれは分析して
あのカーボンテストに入れたりしてね
年代をきちんと計算して
この年でしたとかね あれで楽しいんですよ
ただそれだけ 宇宙の研究もそういうもので
全然役に立ちません ただ
あの人類の財産は何兆単位で使って
何か一つ空に打ち上げて
それでグチャグチャにされて
あれ あれ壊れたとかね
写真撮られたとかね この間何か惑星を発見しました
かなり遠いところで ニュースありましたね
日本の新聞で流してたっけ
あれは  BBC かな これ
まあ今日は夕飯の気持ちはなかったんだからデータ取ってないんですけど
もうちゃんともう長い名前の星で
で 同じあのミルキーウェイ
同じ銀河系ね で しかし
どちらかというと真ん中辺にある太陽なんですけど
すごい弱い太陽なんですね
それで 地球と同じ地球よりすごい大きい惑星を発見したんだと
で これ惑星だから あのどうしても見ることはできません
我々に見られるのはもう太陽ばっかしですからね
そこでどうやって発見するのかというと
アインシュタインの公式を使うんですね
光は曲がるんだと そこであの
この惑星がこの太陽の前に横切っていくと
太陽から来る光が曲がるんですね
それで計算して まあこういう惑星がこれぐらいのものあるんだと発見するんです
かなり難しいことなんですけど
結構時間かけて計算しなくちゃいけないしね
それですごいこと発見していますよ
だから何になるのかと
あれは 温度が出てるんですよ
あれ 太陽自体がすごい弱いんだからね
ものすごい マイナスなんとかなんとか何度でもずっとあるんだと
だからそちらも命があるというふうには全くないんだぞとか
だから全然役に立ちませんだけど
人間調べるんですよ そんなことは
それも知識なんですね
あれはただ楽しいんですね
刺激が与えて このように 2種類の知識があります
もう一つ危険な知識もあって
俗世間の知識はすべてミスです
金になる知識と金にならないで楽しい知識と危険な知識なんです
すべて 危険な知識って何でしょうかと
怒り 欲 憎しみの感情で他人を破壊するために
他人に迷惑苦しみを与えるために開発する知識
これは危険な知識なんですね
武器の開発とかね それは自己破壊の知識にもなります
例えば今 アメリカのね
もう戦闘機なんかには
この夜全く光がなく 真っ暗闇で飛べるんですね
もう光は要りません いろいろ機械を開発して
まあ音で もう赤外線で
あるいはもうレーダー信号で
もうそれで もうスピードでもう飛行機を飛ばしちゃう
真っ暗闇でもヘリで来て
もう森の中でも人間がいると明確に見えるんだと
そんな知識開発するの人殺すためなんですね
うまくいかない それでも負けちゃいますからね
勝った覚えがないんだから
アメリカは ではイラクで勝ってますかね
あれで計算してみると
もうものすごい負けでしょうね
すごい財産と命なくなってるでしょうに
しかし そういう知識はもう危険な知識
あってはならないんです
開発してはならないんですよ
開発しちゃうとどうしても使いたくなるんです
普通に自分と他人とですね
自分と他人の役に立つ良い知識でも
心が汚れたら危険な知識に変わるんですよ
例えば ごく普通に学校で大学で勉強した知識でも
それも良い知識でしょ
それも心が汚れると悪い知識になるんです
具体的な例でいえば このコンピューターの知識がありますね
これ 結構金になりますよ
プログラミングできるならば
エンコーディングできるならば
かなりお金になります
それであまりにもプログラミングの能力ができちゃって
それから欲が出てくる
金儲けてやるぞ そうなってきて
銀行のあれ インターネットネットワークにアクセスする
アクセスして他人のお金を自分のものにする
人のパスワードやら口座番号やらクレジットカード番号やら盗んだりする
すごい頭がいいんでしょうね
でも逮捕されて大変なことになりますね
結局 だから良い知識でも心が汚れると悪い知識に変わってしまうんです
頭の良いものって何でしょうか？と
自分と他人の幸福になる知識
頭には良いんです 理解と理性を養う知識も良いんです
慈しみと智慧を育てる知識
怒り 欲 嫉妬 憎しみ 高慢などの汚れをなくす知識
客観的にあるのままに物事を観察できるようになる知識
まあ最後はまあ仏教を学んじゃえばね
一番清らかな知識なんです
もうかなり頭にはいいんです
どこまででも頭を開発して発展していくもんです
そんなのは頭に良いものなんです
知識の中で 頭に悪いものといえば
怒り 欲などの感情が増える思考
知識 ですから この戦争ゲームなんてのはゲームであろうとも危ないんですよ
戦うゲームとか 時々子供の頭がおかしくなっちゃって人殺しに行っちゃいますね
ドイツでありましたから
ケースですわね 何かゲームやっちゃってやっちゃって
それでもうもう実際のやりたくなっちゃって
自分の部屋からもうもう鉄砲で何人か撃って殺しちゃったんですね
だから戦争ゲームやらね
戦いのゲームは たとえゲームであっても良くない
それから日本の漫画でもちっちゃな子供たちに見せますけど
かなり攻撃的で 道徳はひとかけらもないんですね
ただもうもう悪いことをしたらかっこいいやというぐらいで
もうそれで言葉が悪くなるわ
性格が悪くなるわというのは良くないんですよ
だから怒り欲増える知識は良くない
論理的でない知識 盲信に基づいた知識
脅されて怯えに基づいて得た知識
例えば絶対的な神様の話する宗教は脅しと怯えなんですね
それで怖くなっちゃって
自分たちが信仰する聖書にあるものをそのまま正しいと思ったりするんですね
それでかなり危険なことになっちゃうんです
他人に害を与える目的で得た知識
競争心で得た知識 それから妄想
これって完全に頭に悪いんです
このリストは人間が亡くなっちゃうんです
まあ終わります そろそろ知識の加え方
まあ知識も体力も似たものですよ
体力の加え方を知ってるんだったら同じことです
加え方も似てるんです
えっ？えっ？鍛え方 鍛え方は似てるんです
体に食べ物が必要と同じく
知識にも新たな知識を加えてあげなくてはならないんです
体に食べ物必要でしょ
ずっと 知識にもずっとフィードバック
フィードインしなくちゃいけないんです
同じですよ 知識と体が
体にも心にも運動が必要です
食べるだけで健康にならないでしょ
運動もしなくちゃいけないんですね
知識も同じです 新しい知識を入れただけではダメです
運動させないと それを使って知識を使って何かしないと
もう加えることになりません
悪い食べ物で悪い運動で体が壊れるように
悪い知識で悪い運動で心が壊れて
さらに不幸になる 悪い食べ物をすると体が壊れますね
運動はいいんだけど 悪い運動でちゃうと大変なことになるんです
同じく悪い知識 体に心に入れちゃうと心が病気になるし
悪い運動をしちゃうとまた壊れます
例えば妄想っていうのは悪い運動なんですよ
論理的に考えることは悪い運動じゃないんです
これだからこうなって
これでこうなって だからこうなるんじゃないかなとかね
妄想っていうのはそうじゃなくて
ただもうただなんて言いますか
出てきて 出てきて 出てきて回転するんですね
それで頭の運動なんですけど
悪い運動なんです 妄想は
で 頭 まあ期待ですね 自分と他人の役に立つ知識なら苦労を惜しまず
その知識を得る これで頭良くなりますよ
役に立たない知識に悪い知識に対する執着を捨てる
いろんなことを勉強しなくちゃいけないと欲が出るでしょう
それで何を勉強すれば私のためにもなって
他の人のためにもなるのかと
あ これなら役に立ちそうと思ったら
とことん苦労をします
それを勉強すればいいんです
役に立たない知識に対しては
もう要りませんと そんなのは勉強しませんと捨てなくちゃいけないんです
何でも知りたいは成り立ちませんので
何を知りたいかと判断する必要があるんです
だから何でも知りたいっていうのはありえないんですよ
世の中で一人一人が何を知りたいかということを決めたら
いわゆる上限 知識にも上限を作るんです
心の汚れが減る 知識は加えるごとに幸福感
充実が増すのです それである知識によって心の汚れが減るんですよ
例えばブッダの話を勉強すれば
心の怒りも欲も無知もどんどん減っていくんですよ
それで勉強すればするほど
人はすごく充実感 幸福感を感じるようになるんです
西洋の哲学でも それなりの理性に基づいて
もう普遍的な人間の語るものを勉強すると
なんとなく気分がいいんですよね
そういうことで 心の汚れが減る
知識は得た方がいいんです
知識を乗り越えた知恵
仏教はさらに言うんですね
知識を乗り越えて知恵を得なさいと
まあ項目だけで終わります
あるのままの事実を知ることは知恵です
知の立場から言えば最終知です
知っていうのはいつでも不完全で
開発途上なんです それは承知にすると最終決断結論に行くんです
それが知恵ということなんです
知るべきものを知り尽くすことで
最終的な正しいことを知ることで
最高な幸福を得る 心が二度と汚れない状態になる
生きる苦しみが完全に消える
仏教はこの悟りの知恵を目指して精進することを勧める
この 3番目もありますということで
知恵もありますと 知恵を目指しましょうということで
だから 科学者が最終的にすべての秘密を発見するまで待つと
何億年待てばいいかわからないんですね
そのより先に地球が滅びちゃうでしょうに
だから科学的に事実を発見するまで待っちゃうと
もうダメなんですよ すぐ今
知恵を発見しなくちゃいけない
それには因果法則っていうものがあります
因果性 それを見る見方があります
だからそれで正しく知ることはできるんです
その見る方法っていうのはずっと仏教で教えてありますので
正しい承知が現れたら
もう反論 結論が正しいし
行動も正しいし 苦しみは完全に消える
なぜならば 生きるものは幸福になりたいと生きているんだから
問題は道が間違っているだけ
それも知ることが正しくないんだからないんです
それ直しちゃえば OK です
承知が入ったらもう完全たる幸福を得るんです
それはもう最後の話で
それで話は終了いたします
どうでしょうか 孫が 13歳
香港から来ていました
どうしてあるべきか 要因では
という質問 うん 聞かれてもちょっと答えられないです
それは酒飲んだら頭が悪くなるからでしょうに
頭が悪くていい？いいわけないでしょ
酒ってのは直接頭に影響与えるでしょ
飲んだ途端にもう頭に酒が入っちゃって
脳細胞をもうベチャベチャもう混乱させるんですよ
だから人間のもう唯一の宝物は脳細胞なんでしょうに
それ守っておかないと
みんなもう酒飲んだってそんな問題ないでしょと思ってるでしょうにね
そうじゃないんですよ
脳細胞たくさんあるんだから
もう壊れても大丈夫ですけど
それが情けない人間でしょ
いっぱい脳細胞あるんで
それ全部使っちゃうと
なんかすごい人間になりますよ
だからすごい人間になる可能性あるのに
ただ生きるためだけのちょこっとしか脳細胞を使ってないんで
だから残り脳細胞は迷惑だからそれ酒飲んで壊してるんです
だからまあこれはわかりやすく言えば
すごい大きな家を持った持った人が
私は大きな家をもう面倒くさい
もう掃除はしたくないと言って
全部壊して壊して 小さな部屋の中に隠れてるような感じなんです
もう大きな宮殿にお城に住んでるのに
だから能力なくなっちゃうと小さな部屋に閉じ込まれますよ
だからどんな人間もそれやってますよ
酒飲んで もっとすごい大きい穏やかな心で
すごい知恵があって すごい知識があって
ものすごい立派に生きていられるはずなんです
だから酒飲んだら嘘を言うわ
人を騙すわ 喧嘩するわ
恥ずかしいことをするわ
情けないことをするわ
それからこれもまた悪いし
単なる興奮するために酒飲んでますよ
興奮したらダメっていうことははっきりわかってるでしょうに
例えば酒飲まなくても
この何でしたっけ？サッカーとかね
ありますね このサッカーとかね
そういうところに行ってみんな興奮しちゃって
キャーキャーやってえらい喧嘩になるでしょ
これ一番イギリスでは有名ですからね
サッカー試合があると
もう大変危ない お互いに殴り合って喧嘩になるんです
それも興奮の結果なんですよね
その場合はもう酒を持ってくるなよ
いろんな条件をつけますよ
それ酒持って入る行かなくても
サッカー試合見たら興奮しちゃって
お互いに喧嘩して屋根から落として人が死ぬわとかね
だから興奮すること自体が良くないんですよ
パニックは良くないんですよ
例えば地震が起きても
パニックになった人には何もできない
この地震が起きて この建物が壊れてきたっても
パニックのない人は心からここから壊れているんだ
じゃあこちらに逃げようとかね
なんのことなく逃げますよ
だから人間 なんで酒飲むのかというと
わざとパニック状態になるためなんです
だからそれはまあ自分で喜んで
あの 何て言いますか 針
針ばっかりある もう穴に飛び込むようなものなんですね
勇気を肝試しするぞと
勇気があるんだから もう崖から飛び込んでみるぞと
勇気がないには死にますからね
そういうわけで 酒っていうのは決して良くない
まず一番この頭に悪いということでね
脳細胞に はい 他の質問ありますか？はい
承知でない地っていうのが無知であるという理解と
あの承知は知恵であるということでの理解でよろしい
承知になるともう知恵なんですね
それでいいんです その理解は
承知でないものは無知と言ってもよろしいんです
もう一つ はい 本で読んだことあるんですけれども
あの心からですね 心配した気持ちで
あの花とか植物にあの話しかけると
それがあの なんとなく伝わるような
あの まあ萎えてしまった花が元気になったりとかする現象があるということがちょっと書かれた本も読んだことあるんですけれども
植物にもやっぱり認知する機能っていうものがあるんです
それはわかりませんだけど
物質に物質より心は 心はやっぱり優先度支配者なんですよ
だから物質はそれなりにちょこちょこっと変化するんですよ
心によって 例えば鉄ならどうせも錆びるでしょうし
でも人がそれは自分の何か大事な宝物やと
何か鉄でできたものでも
すごく大事に可愛がって持っちゃうと
なかなか錆びないってことがあるんですよね
物理学とは違うことがやっちゃうんですよ
普通の物質でも でも植物の場合は反応が早いんです
だから自分の心の波動が映るんです
はいはい  先ほどのお酒の話と関係があるんですが
自分より立場が上の人
具体的に言うと 私のおうちに当たる人なんですが
その家とかに行きますと
これは礼儀だからお酒を飲みなさいということみたいで
お酒を勧めてくるんですね
そういった場合に私はお声を守って生活をしたりし
それを守りながらやっているんですけど
季節ごとに行かなきゃならないんで
そうするとやっぱ礼儀とまではならないんですけど
まあ飲みなさいよっていう風に言われちゃうんですね
で そのそういうことはやらないという風に
そのおじを説得するにはどうしたらいいでしょうか
その場合 あまり説得しなくていいんですよ
私は嫌やと言えばいいんです
大体若者っていうのは
すごい頑固でわがままだったらみんなちょこっと手を引くんです
それを使ってください
説得するのは難しいんです
仲が悪くなってしまうと大変です
いえいえ ただもうわがままってそんなに仲が悪くならんですよ
例えば私は豚肉は嫌だ
チキンだけだと言っても仲が悪くならないでしょ
まあそれぐらいのわがままはみんな大体理解するんですよ
また 自分のわがままを他人にバレた方が
他人がもう管理しやすいと思ってるんです
あ あの人だったらもう豚肉には目がないんだからといって
家に来ると豚肉いっぱい作っておくんです
もうそんなあの人はもうラーメンは大好きだから
じゃあラーメン作っておこうかなとかね
そうやってみんなこの他人の弱みを握って他人を管理しようと思ってます
それを逆に使うんです
だから私は嫌やと もう飲み飲みたくないよ
まずいんだと というふうにね
なんでまずいものを飲まなくちゃあかんかと
これは美味しいと感じる人はそれでいいんだけど
まずいと感じる人はまずいでしょうと
これどうしようもないんだと
いうことで わがまま出しちゃえば一応解決します
はい  声望とかに 釣り物に酒を売ることはやめた方がいいですか？やめた方がいいですか？そのおじさんに
そのおじさんに  そのおじさんにとってはね
まあそれは別にどうせ飲むでしょ
だからまあそれはそれで別にどうってことはないと思いますけどね
ありがとうございました
他の方は  それでちょこっと礼儀に対して一言皆さん勉強しなくちゃいけないんだけど
その場合 みんな困ると思いますよ
これは礼儀だから飲みなさいというとね
だから礼儀っていうのは
あの何人かの間の礼儀だけでしょうに
普遍的な礼儀じゃないでしょうに
例えば日本では酒飲むことは礼儀で
別な国ではそれは じゃないし
それぞれ家族に家族の礼儀があって
会社に会社の礼儀とかで
そんなに乗っちゃうと
もう生きていられないんですね
だからまあ普遍的な礼儀っていうものを探し出した方が正しくないのかと思いますけどね
だからまあ 今のケースでは
でもおじいさんがそれ礼儀だからのみなさん
それはおじいさんの礼儀でしょうと
世界みんなそう思ってないんだよと
だから世界の礼儀にしたらどうでしょうかっていうこと
答えなんですけど 自分だけの殻に閉じ込まれて
そこで礼儀決めたってもの殻破ったら違うでしょうと
だから問題は原因と結果だよと
酒飲んで良い結果があるのかということで考えたらいいでしょうかということ
答えなんですけど あの方のおじいさんはそれはそうじません
だから私は言った方法でよろしいと思いますけど
礼儀っていうのは普遍的でなければいけないということだけ勉強してください
はい うん ちょっと聞こえない
映画とか小説で  レクション出してください
こういうところ うん  小説とか映画
小説とか映画とかで 論理的にとか
論理的ではないけれども
よくよく読んでその中に入り込む形で自分の感情が刺激されるとか
そういった小説から読みとかって
それはあまりこうやりすぎると頭
やりすぎると当然良くないんですよ
まあなんとかそう私もさ
今子供向けに書いている小説を読んでいるんです
これ 17巻があるんです
12 12 です で  1 巻は面白かったんですけど
子供のバカバカらしい世界だからね
もう妄想の世界で風邪を引いちゃったでしょうに
えらい苦しいんですよ
あれ 概念もごちゃごちゃ
もうとにかくもう決めたんだから終わりまで読みますけど
今もう 6番目の本は読んでますけど
あの吸血鬼の話でね ダレンシャン
だから無茶はもう頭おかしくなるんですね
だから この  それで理性を使ってね
もう何のために読むのかっていうね
ことは考えた方がよろしいと思います
私の場合は このまあ作家のね
表現力と子供の世界はどう理解しているのかっていうことなんですよ
考えているのは それで考えたのは
ダレンシャン書いた人がちょこっと下手やと
それは大人の目で見る子供の世界なんですよ
だから大人から見れば子供っていうのは可愛いんだから
やってることはね でも子供の立場から見ると
どうなのか でもちょこっとここら辺はもううまくいってないような気がするんですね
そんなものを分析しながら読んだりはするんですけど
結構頭に悪いことできます
だからこの妄想ばっかりのものっていうのは
もうかなり悪いんですよ
もうそれほどよくよくいいってことでもないんですね
そういうところで適当に批判能力とかなんとか使わないと
だから なんかのめり  のめり込んじゃあアカンですよ
これがもう客観的に離れて見ないと
例えば理論的でないと
まあどういう小説はもう妄想の作品ですけど
ある論理にのっとって作ってはいるんです
子供のために書く場合は
この論理はもうわざわざともう破ったりはするんですけどね
それもまあ子供ならそうでしょうと思ったりするしかないしね
だからもうどうしても論理的でなくなっちゃうとおかしいんですよ
のめり込んじゃうと もう論理は忘れちゃうんですね
もう何にでものめり込むということは執着することだからね
それはあまり良くないんですね
まあじゅーっとやることはやるんだけど
最後まで別に執着する必要はないんですね
ということで うんうん
よろしいでしょうか えーと
それではちょっと一つの宣伝なんですけど
ちょうど来月の茅野機械館の講演会の二月二十五日の土曜日ですけど
TBS の生命スペシャルというですね
養老孟司さんがジャニーズのTOKIO というグループが司会をやる特別番組が時間番組がありまして
午後九時に二月の二十五日の午後九時から TBS テレビでやるんですけど
それにスマナサーラ先生が出演されますので
ぜひ来月の茅野機械館の日にというのを覚えておいて
ビデオの録画なり テレビの録画しなり
忘れないようにぜひご覧ください
ちょっといろいろ面白い実験なども出てますので
楽しんでいただけると思います
詳しいことはまた後日したりしますので
ご覧ください それでは最後に回向の文を読まれてもらいます
回向の文  佛法僧の三宝に礼拝敬し
戒をのみ 慈悲の瞑想とヴィパッサナー修行によって積まれたこの功徳を
神々 先祖 祖母 両親 親族
恩師をはじめとし 一切の人々人々に回向いたします
この功徳によって すべての人々人々は幸福に暮らせますように
そして解脱を得られますように
サッビーティオーヴィパッジャントゥ サッバローゴーウィナッサトゥ マーテーバワットワンタヤーヨー スティーディーガーユコ
ー ଭヴェ ヴァーワトゥ サッバマングラン ラッカントゥ サッバデーヴァター サッバブッダヌバーヴェーナ サッバダンマ
ヌバーヴェーナ サッバサンガーヌバーヴェーナ サダー ソッティーバワントゥテー アビワダナシーリッサー ニッチャンワッダーパ
チャイノー チャッターローダンマーワッダンティー アーユワンノー スカンバラン
サーダサーダサーダ  はい
では終了です どうもありがとうございます